hello everybody I'm Doug Walker and with
me is yo uncle yo yes and he's very
excited cuz we're at kinetic on right
now and of course we can't be at kinetic
on without reading some smut so we have
some really fascinating smut as soon as
I found out this existed I said we gotta
film ourselves reading this for those
that watch demo reel all two of you
there's a scene where Donnie Duprey
meets up with uncle yo and he says he's
always had this fantasy that somebody
would write slash Vic about him or just
fanfiction in general and sure enough
somebody has written slash pic about
Donnie Duprey at Uncle yo is the point
where live journal needs to become dead
journal and my name is now and we are
going to read it for you right now
and I think my absolute favorite is that
there's a little warning here it says
warning slash fluff and intense Pocky
kissing I don't know what Pocky kissing
is but I get the feeling we're gonna
find out so let's find out together
we'll exchange the paragraph to pick out
okay it's called the Pocky game all
right after running back up to the hotel
room Donnie took a huge gasp of breath
boy was he out of shape uncle yo hey the
two continued to chuckle learning so
much about how much fun these places
could be especially when you're hanging
out with someone who is willing to do so
much with you even in such a short
amount of time it was a wonder really
how a friendship could blossom so
quickly at places like these and even
share an unspoken bond just by hanging
out once he was handed the beer they
both reached for the bottle opener at
the same time they both froze for a
second when their ads touched Donnie
took his chance to remove the cap on his
beer smiling he held up the bottle
toward his friend here is to you finding
out what tentacle hentai is about
without screaming
I don't like where this is going that's
not in there I'm just saying that shit
is crazy uncle y'all snickered what
pretty kinky maybe for you but before
Tony could finish
uncle yo just gave out her quick hearted
laugh ha ha
dude it's fine whatever uncle yo said
with a shrug while Donny rolled his eyes
and gave a chuckle with him ah so cool
yo gave another chuckle ha ha if we're
waving his hand to dismiss the subject
holding up the beer for Donny ha ok it's
mine real ready giving a blink or two
before holding up his beer who is that
Donny gave a nod and a smile ready ok 1
2 3
and they both began to chug their beer
Donny gripped the blanket yes he
swallowed as much of the nasty liquid as
he cooked okay Sam Adams is a prime
lager then Donny choked is this all
symbolic a V is that where the edge
holds last fiction comes in if he
couldn't take it anymore
damn it do you have to tease him his
pride does not need to be poked thank
you very much and that's not in quotes
oh I guess that's just writer commentary
maybe some sweets will do you good
he offered as he took one of the sticks
from the pocky box
you know the chugging contest reminds me
of another game but it involves the
pocky how is it go
oh well it's um come on come on tell me
you told me a lot about the con and its
quirks already why stop now you ever
play the one game gay chicken
eyebrows raised well basically what you
do is with the pocky taking out a stick
he demonstrated by pointing to each end
of the Pocky each person takes one end
of the Pocky oh Christ
this is really hot you both come to the
middle trying to get the most Pocky and
the one who breaks off first
Donnie's jaw dropped a bit give me a
couple of blinks before shaking his head
and clearing his throat just I've never
there was an awkward silence that filled
the room then Anka yo gave her a side
before standing up to get another beer
I'm sorry just thought that you might
get a laugh out of it or something
pausing uncle yo noticed a hand grabbing
his arm he was rather intimidating since
he was Oso taller than the other it is
true this is too good observation
uncle yo took a step back as he shook
loose his arm from Donny's crypt staring
at the Paki that was now wedged in the
tall ones teeth after a while you simply
become just that's all shit maybe
Elizabeth Lizzie is that you at the gay
part uncle yo gave a determined nod as
he opened his lips and took the other
end of the Pocky stick through his teeth
he spoke to Donny well do this on the
count of three Donny moved his lips
slightly Jessica okay the Pocky game
between the two men as they nibbled away
at the Pocky toward each other Donny's
heart was beating so fast who's almost
forgot where they were what they why
they were standing Uncle yo kept pecking
way faster toward him looking determined
as ever they would be closer and closer
hurry she got to grab Johnny shirt to
drive him there uncle yo uncle yo winces
eyes shut as he got closer to the others
lips bending down to reach the other as
they close the space between the Donny
made his way to finish his bakiyev then
there in the mists of the little war on
the Pocky they kissed
Oh lips pushed against each other as
they froze both knowing about the rule
the first who breaks away
loses Donnie didn't know what to do
uncle yo however wrapped his arms around
Donnie's oh come on now lashing out his
tongue in determination to retrieve the
rest of that Pocky that was in Donnie's
mouth Donnie now decided he couldn't let
uncle yo win that guy had already wanted
their little drinking contest earlier he
was not gonna back down not this time
Tony came out a slight low growl at the
back of his throat as he pushed his
tongue back against the others huh no
way the pair of their pants now brushing
against each other as they continued
their kiss things were starting to get
really intense and it wasn't just the
heat that rose in the battle legs
wrapped around each other's as they
rolled around on the bed stop no no no
soon uncle yo was on the bottom died of
a lie almost completely forgetting about
the Pocky
it was almost almost the fill it wasn't
until they rolled back again as uncle
you aggressively tug back to take charge
against Donnie
I want that Paki Donnie let's go as he
sat up a bit you broke off first I
didn't I know
but Donnie you're done what I'm what
you should be doing this I mean we
should be dot dot dot they're just
friends that's it don't fool yourself
Donny that's all at what I love the ride
with commentary him is like the writer
is like the fan read to get Donny
there's something I want to ask Leo was
about to ask him when a certain German
opened the door wide as he entered into
the room grumbling as he adjusted the
camera he was holding it no it don't you
two ever thought about leaving the door
open a job then you are expecting a
third person damn don't cough only one
more day until this con was over and
they sure will remember what they've had
here together they will never forget it
I'll find you and skin you alive little
teenager who wrote are going to be sued
sued by us burned at the stake
you have made some powerful enemies my
friend Sam Adams is good bear it is very
good beer Boston lager is awesome and we
do not do Pocky games like that we do it
out of our anuses what but why it
brought you up here it's why the doors
locked you didn't notice that it liked
from the inside